it gives me the greatest pleasure to
announce these awards
it is remarkable as to the achievements
and activities taking place
across rochford district which would go
without recognition without events such
as this
i am pleased that i am able to publicly
thank and recognize people
who give up their time selflessly in
order to make a huge difference to
others
this past year has been particularly
difficult and we are so lucky in
rockford district to have such a strong
sense of community i am delighted that
we
receive such strong nominations this
year and would like to thank you all for
what you do and i hope that you have
inspired many others to follow in your
footsteps
to us to achieve great things
this year's citizen of the euro war goes
to isabelle
buckley who has gone above and beyond
not only with our district
but throughout essex and the east of
england using her voice to bring social
change for young people
isabelle sets an excellent example to us
all
congratulations